nous nous mettons à travailler
gratuitement en nous mettant là-bas dans l'
espoir que les gens feront un don et cela a
eu une réponse si énorme non seulement nos
travailleuses du sexe aidant une bonne cause, mais
nous montrons également au monde que de
vraies personnes faisaient de vrais  travailler et nous
avons tous bon cœur un corps n'est qu'un corps
et si c'est quelque chose que je peux vous
savez offrez-moi d'aider le monde et bien
sûr je vais le faire et bien sûr je
vais utiliser ma plate-forme pour le faire
[Musique]
J'ai vu sur son Instagram qu'elle avait
une petite suite relativement petite mais
elle a réussi à amasser 30 000 $ en
quelques heures seulement, alors sachant que j'avais une
suite similaire sur Twitter, j'ai décidé
de la copier et de la coller.
message exact ça me rend si heureuse et fière
de savoir que je fais partie de ces personnes
et de ces femmes qui veulent
aider et changer le monde même si cela
signifie simplement que nous vendons notre corps
et que nous sommes  utiliser des photos nues pour le faire
comme si c'était beau pour moi et que c'était
très entrepreneurial et très
euh vous savez une incitation pour les gens à
vouloir participer même si ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui
leur est proche personnellement je '  J'ai toujours
été vraiment passionné par les animaux et
en particulier par l'Australie. Je savais juste que cela
aiderait. Je savais juste que le sexe vendait
vraiment et si vous identifiiez une bonne
cause,
il savait juste que cela inciterait les gens,
en particulier en fonction du montant que
Kaelin  avait suscité quand j'ai commencé
[Music]
les réactions que j'ai reçues ont été
absolument incroyables, les gens
me disent littéralement que je fais le travail de Dieu
comme si je n'avais pas reçu de
réponses négatives à part le temps des trolls sur Internet
essayant de revendre mes nus et
divulgué mon  les nouvelles qui ont été le seul
mauvais contrecoup que j'ai eu et c'est du
karma sur eux n'a rien à voir avec moi
je fais toujours ma part je pense que
cela va changer la façon dont
les gens participent et agissent
que ce soit au sein du gouvernement  ou
avec les catastrophes mondiales, je pense que nous pouvons
tous apprendre de cette expérience parce que
ça a été tellement incroyable et les réponses
ont été tellement tellement encourageantes pour tous ceux
qui ont des choses négatives à dire, je pense
qu'ils pourraient tous le sucer parce
qu'honnêtement ce que je '  je pense que ce n'est pas une
belle chose que je souhaite qu'ils ne soient pas
si étroits d'esprit et je souhaite qu'ils
apprécient simplement ce que je fais et
essaie d'aider le monde et j'essaie
d'aider le pays et  même si cela
signifie que j'utilise mon corps et ce que je fais dans
la vie pour aider à encourager qu'il
doit encore y avoir une plus grande prise de conscience,
les gens doivent savoir que ces incendies
brûlent toujours et l'étendue de ce qu'ils
ont fait et des dommages causés à  ce
pays, l'Australie, le monde
vous voit enfin, je comprends que les incendies
font rage depuis septembre et je
ne pense pas que vous ayez obtenu la
couverture dont vous aviez besoin jusqu'à présent, j'ai l'
impression que vous avez tous les yeux sur vous
maintenant, je veux dire  les choses deviennent virales
à votre sujet et j'espère que vous recevez
les dons et l'aide dont vous avez besoin